great thank you claudio uh and thank you
to the organizers a pleasure to be here
and to be part of this
uh to be engaging with this really
interesting semester and
workshop um so i want to talk today
about um products of projective spaces
and let me give a kind of set up so
we'll imagine we have a
say a sub-variety
product of projective spaces p to the n1
up to p to the nt so a bunch of factors
and my kind of overall goal
is to compute
facts about the chief comology
of x
so so i'll tighten the focus in a moment
um and
say a little more about the kinds of
things i want to
compute in this situation um but but
what i'm going to do today is talk about
two new results
and give a kind of flavor of two new
results that
provide answers to this question and
and what i find most interesting about
them is they show that as a very
different flavor
than the corresponding questions for
projective space itself so kind of new
phenomena and new challenges arise
uh when you try to move from the case of
a single factor projective space
to a to a this kind of multi-factor
situation
so let me start by by setting things up
over projective space itself and
reviewing some some of that situation
and please if i write too low or the
marker gets
too dull or something just get it new
marker already
get a new marker already that's what i
was wondering all right so let's get rid
of i'll just throw it out
get a brand new marker all right
all right so let's start over pn so so
we'll start with the case for pn
i should say i'm going to be over an
arbitrary field here the field is going
to play no
no role in anything i say
so i'll let s
be the polynomial ring and n plus one
variables
with the standard grading so the degree
of x sub i is one for
for all i of course is the coordinate
ring for projective space
and and there's a well-known
correspondence between
algebraic objects on on the coordinate
ring
and and geometric objects for projective
space so if you have an
a sub variety of projective space that
corresponds to an ideal
in in the polynomial a graded ideal on
the polynomial ring
um and and so on if you have a a
coherent sheaf
a pn that corresponds to a
graded module m is a finitely generated
rated module and the correspondence is
you could say that e
is what you get if you take the module m
and you shifify it you take the
corresponding sheaf
so as a special case you could think
that m is the coordinate ring
of a sub-variety or something but but i
want to work in this level of generality
and i'm kind of interested in in two
slightly more specific questions so i
want to study
questions about vanishing
so
for what integers can we say
that that the chief colonology groups
e twisted by a is zero
okay and of course i should be uh
greater than zero so for what values of
a did the kind of higher cosmology
groups vanish that's that's one sort of
question i'm interested in
and and the second is just a more
precise or
you know version of this which is in
full generality what is the dimension
of these chief colmology groups can you
actually compute them
on the nose when when they don't vanish
and and for projective space i'll review
a little bit how kind of answering these
two questions
questions about vanishing and
computation amounts to
to a discussion of how should you
represent your sheaf
as as kind of an object in in say
macaulay too right if you want to put it
into macaulay too what's the best way to
do it
and there are a few different approaches
to to representing
you know putting an object into to
macaulay too or to representing a sheaf
explicitly and and those have different
advantages and disadvantages
and and i want to review those a little
bit because that'll be the foundation
for for what follows
so the first approach
is to take a minimal free resolution
so here the idea is you have your module
m and you resolve it
and each fi
is a graded free
s module
in particular
so i mean this is a very common
technique um and
and it's it's very
possible to do it on a computer i mean
in some ways this is the killer
application of macaulay 2
is is if you if you write down a graded
module as a kernel or a
co kernel or something then macaulay 2
can very efficiently
compute the minimal graded free
resolution of it and
produces the betty table and you can
study lots of properties about m
by kind of approaching the the minimal
free resolution
and this representation um is good for
actually maybe i'll squeeze it in down
here it's just one line
i mean it's good for far too many things
to list i mean minimal free resolutions
are
good for detecting if if a module is
cohen mccauley they're good for
computing the depth of the module
you can compute the hilbert function the
hilbert polynomial you can compute lots
of subtle geometric invariants
i mean it's kind of good for many things
there's a whole book by by david
eisenberg called the geometry of
syzygies that's entirely about
uh all the information the kind of
subtle information you can find in this
um but for the purposes of today i want
to focus on one aspect of it
which is it's good for kind of sharp
vanishing questions
so if you want to know the range of
values a for which you get the chief
chromology groups to vanish
the minimal free resolution of the
module really tells you that and it
tells you that on the nose
and and it's encoded by an invariant
known as castle nuovo mumford
regularity and i'll return to this later
on and
and discuss it in more detail
but for now that's kind of the point if
you have the minimal free resolution you
get a really great answer to this
question you get kind of a perfect
answer
to this question okay so that's one
approach
there's a second approach which
um you don't think of that often
i guess i don't think most people do
which is i'll take a resolution
up to irrelevant homology
so i mean here you have to go back and
remember what is the uh the
correspondence between graded s modules
and coherent sheaves
and and it's not unique right it's not
one to one there's you know two
two finally generated graded modules
give the same coherent sheath
if the two modules are kind of
equivalent up to something supported
on the irrelevant ideal on the maximal
ideal of the polynomial ring right so
there's a
an imperfect correspondence so in other
words instead of resolving
a module m i could choose a
i could use kind of a different module a
truncation of m or something like that
and look at the minimal free resolution
of that so
so for instance um if you know if
so if you have some other module
and this that uh if you feel a map
between two modules like this that
yields an isomorphism
in high degrees
then m prime and m
give the same sheaves and so you could
consider
resolving m prime instead of m
and this is something that we don't talk
about so much and it's because if i
asked what it's good for i
i think the honest answer is it's not
good for that much i mean
it's a kind of useful idea to talk about
truncating modules and high degrees
if you're interested in global questions
like the hilbert scheme the construction
of the hilbert scheme
involves kind of studying uh you know i
don't know
truncating modules in high degree and
parameterizing them that way but but if
you're interested in kind of a single
sheath and you want to study it
it's almost always best to represent
your sheath
by by the unique saturated module that
that corresponds to it right so so
there's usually a best representative
and and you work with that and we kind
of rarely ever work with these
these other guys that that only agree up
to irrelevant homology
um but i mentioned this approach because
this is a feature that's going to be
very different when we pass to products
of projective spaces so
so whereas the minimal free resolution
is kind of always the best
approach if you want to talk about
resolutions um
this kind of flexibility is going to be
increasingly powerful
as as we move to the multi-projective
space situation
all right we can make that seem a little
more precise what do you mean
yeah so what i mean is um so there's a
unique
biggest or littlest the unique biggest
if you uh let's see what's the right way
to say this
um you can make this correspondence
more or less unique if uh
you have to if you ignore like points
right if you have an ideal shape of a
pointer
and then use that you want to take the
what
you will
you have something that is a quotient of
let's say
s by an ideal right and you're saying
that what you want to do is you want to
take the radical
exactly you want to take the exactly the
right well yeah if it's the primary or
the radical or the saturation
with respect to the maximal ideal is is
kind of the best approach
so yeah if you're talking about a
variety right if you're talking about an
ideal the models are you have
kind of a single saturated ideal or you
can you can take like
i and you can tack on i don't know like
powers of the maximal ideal
and and these won't contribute to the
geometry
because because adding an embedded point
at the origin is kind of invisible
and and then i claim that that the
minimal free resolution
of i is always better in in some sense
than the minimal free resolution of
of some unsaturated gadget
and that kind of follows from the
outslander books bomb theorem it's
always say
has the minimum free resolution of i is
always shorter
it has less terms in it then then if you
do this
if you tack on a kind of irrelevant
component
the betty numbers are always smaller i
mean it's kind of
always better like a computational point
of view like in macaulay too like is it
is it always
the case that i never want to consider a
non-saturated i don't think i don't
i mean surely i think yes i don't know a
strong statement along those lines but
but the betty numbers in practice if you
pass from i to this the betty numbers
explode they get much larger
and you're computing much you know
they're just much bigger things but i
don't know actually i mean that's a
question for mike is it
ever more efficient to compute a linear
truncation than
the original thing i've never found it
to be the guess
you might not have access to the to i
itself you might just have set theoretic
defining
that's right variety and you don't have
the option to give
the prime ideal for instance yeah that's
right i mean it's you know there's
i mean i'm not saying there's no i mean
there are
there are some uses for for working with
this i mean you get linear resolutions
in this way i mean there are some things
that are kind of useful from this
perspective
but for computational questions i think
if you're able to write down
the kind of prime ideal or the the
saturated object the reduced object
i know of no examples where a
computation
is quicker or or more efficient if you
kind of
add noise right and yeah
sometimes saturation could be in the
model micro viewer
computation yeah yeah no i mean that's
that is a key word right but
all right all right let me talk about a
third approach
um which has a very different flavor
than these two
um talk about balance and monads
and tape resolutions
so to set this up i want to let omega 1
be the cotangent bundle
pn
and we'll write omega to the i
for the ith wedge product
of it and then there's a
famous theorem about representing a
sheath
via via these omega eyes
so i'm not sure all the names that i
should actually attach to this but i'll
attach
the ones who i know are relevant so
i may be missing some
uh so the theorem will go like this e is
still a coherent sheath and the claim is
that there exists a complex
u of e
this is a complex where it goes you know
uh
uei to u
e i minus 1
so on
and the complex has two properties one
is the terms of the complex
are built from the sheaf homology groups
of e
so u i is the direct sum
over
like this where you take the uh
the comology group h k of e twisted by
minus j
and then you tensor with the sheath
omega j twisted by j so
so the terms of this complex are built
by taking certain sheath commonology
groups
uh you know which is a vector space and
and tensoring those with uh
with these these basic building blocks
so these omega i's and so
so instead the free resolution case is
like representing a sheath
via free modules or via line bundles if
you like and here instead of using line
bundles i'm using
powers of the cotangent bundle right but
they're kind of simple objects in their
own right
um and and so the
the complex is built out of chief
chromology and these omega eyes
and it's it's a resolution in some sense
of the sheath so it's a monad for the
sheath it's the more precise way to say
it
which means that if you look at the
coilology of the complex so the ith
chomology sheath of the complex
this is e itself when i is zero
and zero when i is non-zero
so you get this complex it's got
finitely many terms in it
um and if you look at the homology at
degree zero you get your sheaf back and
it's kind of built up
out of these these simple objects
um it is a little more complicated than
than the other approaches
but it is very implementable in macaulay
2. so so a bit about the history
this was is kind of began with the
theorem of baylenson in
in 78 uh where he proved a variant of
this but
but i believe he didn't he had it
instead of a complex it was a spectral
sequence that converged with these
properties
um and then uh and kona and otoviani
um was the first place at least that i'm
aware where it was shown that that
spectral sequence actually the maps in
the spectral sequence lift
to to give it as a complex um and then
that
same fact was proven by eisenbud floyd
stud schreier
via a very explicit approach that
involves
passage to to computations over an
exterior algebra
and they proved the same theorem and and
the eisenbud floyster trier one is is
really effective for putting this into
macaulay
ii so you avoid a spectral sequence
computation entirely they kind of have a
way
to to do a computation over an exterior
algebra and produce
this representative of our sheath
kind of the same way you could produce
you know a minimal free resolution of
your sheaf right so
so you can very explicitly get get your
representative for your sheath
and and this is good for computation so
this is good for the kind of computation
question what is
h i p n e a in general
and and so i'll dive into this in more
detail later on when we get to the
sequel and see what happens in the the
products of projective spaces
um but the kind of overview i wanted to
give was was again we have these
minimal free resolutions which are great
for the vanishing questions
and and we have these kind of balance
and moan ads or and then
tape resolutions on this side uh
which are good for the more detailed
question of actually computing the chief
chromology in general
so when you say good is there any way to
quantify this good
uh i mean so there's there's
you could talk about the complexity of
the algorithm
for computing these things i think um
and
i mean there are different algorithms
for computing chief homology groups in
general and my understanding is there
are
two and it's not clear which is kind of
faster in all cases or maybe some are
faster in some and some are faster than
the other
but one of them arises from this circle
of ideas and
and is kind of certainly the fastest in
many examples
so so it's kind of good for what i mean
it's good for computing these i mean
um primarily what i mean is
computationally if you actually wanted
to compute chief chromology groups of a
given sheaf
it's often the most effective algorithm
kind of derives from this circle of
ideas
so that's more or less what i mean i
mean it's also it's also good from a
from a more theoretical point of view
which is it gives you a representation
of your sheath that relates the chief
chromology groups
to the representation and so you can
also go back and forth if you know
something about the
chief chromology groups you can get
information about the sheaf
kind of go on that one so it's useful as
a theoretical tool too
does that answer your question okay
all right so let me move on to uh to the
product situation
so let's see
actually
so is this a recipe for
computing these callology groups in
which case there has to be some other
way of constructing uav
yes but you're just not telling me and i
haven't told it to you yet
and and i will tell you it's a bit
complicated
the there's just a little info so so
this circle of ideas is kind of what i'm
saying to sweep
it under the rug a bit leads to
algorithms for computing these in
general
and and i'll come back to that when when
i kind of tell you how to do it for
products but it's a little it's a bit of
a long you know
it's not a two-minute story right so i'm
kind of sweeping that under the rug for
now
all right so i want to move on and and
kind of revisit these now in the case of
products of projective spaces
and so i'll consider a two factor
product p a cross p
b um and let me just say
i'm i'm gonna restrict to a two factor
product because
for for the kind of theorems i'm gonna
talk about the transition from one
factor to two factors already has
all of the kind of new complexity so
so going from two factors to three four
five six there's kind of nothing new
so i'll focus on the two factor case
because it'll keep the notation simpler
it's easier to write things on the board
but but everything i say is going to
work for an arbitrary number of factors
too
all right so in this case the kind of
analog
of the the polynomial ring the graded
polynomial ring is a bi-graded
polynomial ring
so this is take the polynomial ring in
a plus one variables which i'll call x's
and b
plus one variables which i'll call y's
and this is what's known as the this is
going to be the cox ring
of pa cross pb
and we'll give it a z2 grading
so it has a bi grading and the by
grading is the degree of the x's
is one of the basis vectors and the
degrees of the y's
are the other basis vector
and again there's there's a
correspondence here so so if you have
you know coherent sheath
on pa cross pb
this corresponds to a finitely generated
i graded s module
and the correspondences is very similar
as before except there's one
difference which is the irrelevant ideal
is a different object so
so the kind of key difference is
the irrelevant ideal on pa cross pv and
if you think of these as coordinates on
the first factor
and the y's as coordinates on the second
factor and
and so the irrelevant idea is if all of
the x's are zero
or if all the y's are zero right you
don't get a point in there so the
irrelevant idea is the intersection
x0xa y 0 up to y
a b and and with this
it's kind of you can you know the facts
that you're maybe familiar with about
the correspondence for projective space
uh and the graded polynomial ring go
through so
so two finally generated modules give
the same coherent sheath
if and only if they're kind of the same
up to irrelevant homology stuff
supported on the irrelevant ideal
and the correspondence goes through um
more or less
straightforwardly once you once you have
those pieces
all right so given so so we could we
could follow approach one right
i could go back and do a minimal free
resolution so i could do
and i could compute the resolution of m
but a problem arises which is it turns
out that that the minimal free
resolution of m
does not give sharp vanishing bounds
okay this is this is kind of
known to people who've studied this
before but but if you
if you look at the minimal free
resolution you do not get
sharp vanishing bounds on on the module
or to say it
more precisely the minimal free
resolution does not kind of see
the castle nuovo mumford regularity in
the bi-graded situation
all right so let me tell you let me
introduce casanova mumford regularity
to to make this more precise
so pn achieve e is
m regular
if
the homology group of e twisted by m and
then you have this funny uh
shift so you do h i of e twisted by a
minus i
that should be zero for all i greater
than zero
so
so a module is m regular if it's kind of
a chief chromology vanishing condition
um and on pa cross pb
there's a similar notion so we'll say
that e
is m1 m2 regular
if appropriate chief chromology groups
vanish so
the hi on the product
but now it's a little trickier because
because what i need to do is i need to
do
let's see it's m1 minus j1
m2 minus j2 i want this to equal zero
for all j1 plus j2
equals i and both of the
the js should be greater than or equal
to zero
so so anyways again it's it's kind of a
chief chromological vanishing condition
you want that
more or less what you want is that the
sheaf homology groups when you twist by
m are zero but there's a little bit of a
shift that you have to worry about in
both cases
um so i should say this definition is
due to uh
this definition is due to mclagan and
smith
um but it appeared uh it also appeared
uh in in some form an earlier work of uh
sidman event tool
it seems to be a slight inconsistency
with the previous definition right
greater than zero for all i greater than
zero thank you dan
i has to be greater than zero yeah you
want the higher comology groups to
vanish of course
you can't expect the h0 to vanish
so the way to think about this and then
the definition i should say is the
regularity
of e uh
is going to be the so fur
back in the two-factor case the
regularity of e
is the set
in z2 such that e is m regular
so the picture you should have in mind
is that if i give you a sheath e
the regularity of e is like a region in
the
the degree space in in the kind of z2
and and mcclagan and smith proved that
the regularity region is invariant under
uh adding elements of the under adding
positive vectors basically so if you
take the region and you shift it up to
the right you
land back in the region so this is kind
of a picture for the regularity
and so instead of the you know instead
of talking about the castle novel
mumford regularity on pn which is
usually an integer which is the smallest
integer where this happens
in the bi-graded case we're interested
in these corners we want to know kind of
if i wanted a sharp vanishing statement
i would want to be able to identify
the kind of spots where where i
start to get these kind of higher chief
chromology vanishing
okay and and the claim is that the
minimal free resolution doesn't see this
all right and and let me do an example
let me show up an example so i put one
on the board
to kind of look at and let's see is this
going to work
so here's an example so i was looking at
look at the cox ring of p1 cross p2
which has five variables two x's and
three y's
and i'm going to look at the the
coordinate ring of the union of two
uh two lines i guess x zero y zero
and x one y one those are two two skew
lines
and p1 cross p2
and if you work out the resolution you
you get this it has the minimal free
resolution it has four
terms so there's an s and these are the
terms that come out
but if you were to kind of use the free
resolution from
the resolution you can get a guess of
what the regularity should be
and your guess would look like this it
would look like that the regularity
region
would uh would start in in corner 1 1
and
and kind of work all the way out
but there's actually more to it so it
turns out that uh and wait let me see
which way is it it turns out that
0 1
should actually be in the regularity
region as well so
so if you look at the free resolution
and you kind of unravel these twists
which
takes takes a little bit of work but if
you unravel the twist
what you would see from the minimal free
resolution is that anything in here
is is a regularity point for the sheath
but
but really there's a hole you're missing
a whole line it's kind of you aren't
getting a sharp bound you're getting the
wrong region
if you look at the minimal free
resolution
and so it turns out that that's because
the minimal free resolution
contains lots of information that is
irrelevant
to the vanishing question to the chief
chromology vanishing question
and and we can already see it in this
example so
so i want to kind of pinpoint something
interesting in this example
so i highlighted these red terms
if you imagine these red terms this is
there's like a quotient
complex with this one two
one as the free modules and the maps are
given by
the the matrices i identified and that's
a kazul complex on two variables
on the x0 and the x1 and remember
x0 and x1 defines the empty set
in my variety right so in other words
this quotient
complex this kind of red quotient
complex
is irrelevant both in the kind of
irrelevant ideal sense but also in the
sense if you wanted to compute
if you wanted to understand the sheaf
that you're resolving
you could literally delete these terms
and you would still have a resolution of
the sheaf what you would have
is what we talked about in approach two
which is
a resolution of something which only
agrees up to irrelevant
homology and and so when you move to the
multi-factor case it turns out
that that you know you can
use the these kind of alternate
free resolutions that are only correct
up to irrelevant homology
and get much better results so what
happens
if we just um re-embed
pa across pb by the segre and then look
at the resolution that larger projective
so what you get is is basically the
resolution the resolution along
the diagonal right the only twists you
would ever see
are are twists where they're both the
same right so you get sharp vanishing
results about the kind of diagonal but
not about
the the kind of corner so in very
particular you'd never see this right
you'd see oh the resolute
the regularity is one right because
you'd be in the diagonal but you
wouldn't see that this kind of one zero
the unbalanced ones were there
and you know you could imagine doing
segre and getting different rational
lines but if you want to do everything
all at once you want to work over the
cox right
so maybe this
using this middle free resolution it
doesn't really understand the module is
supposed to be a sheath on p1 cross p2
but maybe he's treating it like a sheath
on
p4 um i mean someone the vibrating
doesn't really
matter for the resolution so is is this
thing you've boxed there's some kind of
explaining some discrepancy between
these two perspectives yeah i mean what
it's say it's it's the way i think about
it it's a discrepancy between
a2 cross a3 and p1 cross p2
and the discrepancy is you take the
stuff that's supported on the irrelevant
ideal and you throw it away
and and so what i'm saying is you know
if it's if this is the resolution of the
module on
a2 cross a3 like there's no ambiguity
there right
um but when you remove the these kind of
components and you quotient and you get
this irrelevant ideal
there's this flexibility that pops up
and and it was there in the pn case i
just kind of
maybe unconvincingly tried to tell you
that you know
oh we never need that flexibility right
we never want to talk about unsaturated
ideals right
um but i'm saying on products it's i
mean you should be skeptical on products
i'm claiming that
this this flexibility is actually
powerful and there's real
there's real advantage to to working
with these other models
so let me give a theorem that that kind
of captures what we see in this example
so the definition
is we'll let f bullet be a free
complex
by graded s modules
we'll let m be a degree
and we define
wmf bullet as the sub complex
of f uh determined
uh
by selecting the
terms oops
generated
in degrees less than or equal to
m1 plus a m2 plus
b so
so the idea here is is if i wanted to
get the black subcomplex if i wanted to
remove the red sub complex
um that this would be the kind of
resulting black
complex would be let me see if i can get
this right this would be
w sub 1
0 1 0 or 0 1
of f bullet
then i add 1 comma 2 when i erase
well it's i don't know
i actually i was so my i screwed up my
indexing earlier
but this is i mean this is the the
this complex is obtained let's see we
delete everything that has a two in the
second coordinate
so this is something like w sub
oh am i getting this wrong it's like w
one negative one
of f bullet i guess it's the uh the
right answer
so you basically you're picking a degree
and you're deleting everything
that's of too high degree that's the
construction
and the theorem and this is joint work
with christine burkish
zamayeri uh
and greg smith
and the theorem is that if m
is in the regularity of e then
if you do this truncation and you
take the corresponding complex of
sheaves
this resolves the sheath you are
interested in
so so unlike the the projective case um
the minimal free resolution has this
redundant information in it
and you can just if you know something
about the regularity you can just delete
that and work with the kind of much
smaller complex and
and so these guys actually uh
so it's these kind of truncated
complexes that
that get us closer to sharp vanishing
right that connect
the castle nova mumford regularity with
with
free complexes it's these kind of
truncated guys and
the benefit of working with these
truncated guys can be pretty dramatic
you can really
they're they're much smaller in in
practice and so i wanted to do an
example
um to show kind of how this actually
looks because
i think that there's some real potential
for uh let's see i want to do picture
unmute
there are these sorts of ideas to to
help us compute
regularity and and shift yeah some
related things so i'm going to take a
projective space ooh i guess it's
spilling over but it's p1 cross p1 cross
p2
and i'm going to take an idea of six
general points on here
okay so i is the ideal six general
points
and then i resolve i and so the minimal
free resolution
corresponding to to my
ideal um with no irrelevant homology
looks like this it has these you know
huge betty numbers 1
37 120. if you want to see the kind of
graded structure
it's boy it's even worse um so
so this encodes the graded structure so
this says there are 24
generators of a certain degree in f2 and
so on right i mean there's just tons
you know 30 generators of some other
there's just tons and tons of generators
and tons of degrees
so again this is what r looks like um
but if you do this operation if you kind
of shave away
the uh the the stuff that's irrelevant
what you're left with
is is a very small percent of what you
started with so
so it turns out zero zero two is in the
regularity so
so we do our operation to it and and
most of the summands just disappear
entirely i mean we drop from 166 to 42
in that degree you dropped from 45 to
zero in the fifth column i mean it's
just a huge
a huge savings here um if you want to
see it i mean this is the
this last thing these are all the terms
that that play no role
right so all of these terms you know
these 18 guys in degree 2 1
2 they they contributed nothing to chief
chromology computations they were they
were
totally irrelevant somehow um so
i don't know i think i find it to just
be a kind of yeah i mean we were kind of
very surprised
uh uh to discover how much of these
these free resolutions just
is is contributing nothing somehow to
these things
all right um
so for time purposes i'll jump ahead um
let me just yeah
i don't know here um i mean there's some
other interesting things so this is an
interesting example where
where the original ideal wasn't cohen
mcauley but when you add the irrelevant
um homology it suddenly becomes conan
mccauley so you can get other nice
benefits too
from this operation all right
i pressed it twice
okay there we go
uh i'm sure someone can turn the board
lights on thank you
all right so with the remaining time i
want to go deeper into the question of
how to compute
chief comology actually you know instead
of just talking about
understanding the kind of regularity and
when when the sheaves vanish when the
comology vanishes
how do we get at uh how do we actually
produce algorithms
that compute the groups
so this involves um this involves a
circle of ideas that that i said before
dates back to bailinson
and berenstein gelfand gelfand and it's
sometimes known as the the bgg
correspondence and it has its origins
and
in 1978 what i'm going to
explore is is much closer to to the kind
of very explicit version of the theory
uh and detailed version that was worked
out by eisenbud floydstud and schreyer
and and for time purposes i'll just dive
into the story for pa cross pb
so so we're going to think of s
this is the same ring as before so s is
that kind of so all right so we're still
on
and and i have this polynomial ring s
in x variables and y variables
which i want to think of as the
symmetric algebra
on a vector space v
and then i wanted to find e to be
the exterior algebra
on the dual vector space
so i'll think of that if you like as
it's you know it's an exterior algebra
on a dual set of variables oops
so you can see that you know e i is like
x i
dual and f j is like yj
dual and and so it's it's a there's
going to be a graded exterior algebra
and since i'm i'm kind of setting the
variables up like this the degree of e i
will be the negative of the degree of x
j
and so on right there's a there's a
duality here
so given a bi-graded
module m
um there's a uh
there's a map that goes like this so
it's we call it the r
functor you take a bi-graded
s module
you get a free
complex of e-modules
of bi-graded uh e-modules
and it's it's a very explicit
construction so
here's what it looks like
so if your module m is bi-graded it has
a natural decomposition
as a direct sum of vector spaces over
j 1 j 2 and z 2
m sub j 1 j 2.
definition of a bi-graded module and so
what r of m
is going to look like
is a complex
where the i term is the direct sum
over by degrees that add up to i
the i plus first term is the same thing
except now i add up to i plus one
um and so so it's a free module
where the ranks of the graded pieces are
encoded by the bi-graded hilbert
function of m right each of these is
just a k
vector space and so the kind of rank of
the
you know with the the yeah the
the rank of a certain free module is
being encoded by the bi-graded hilbert
function of m
and the differential
consists of block matrices
uh
given by the following map so so i take
you know these block matrices
the part that comes out of the m1 m2
piece
is the map that looks like this i take
the m1 m2 piece
and i map it to two pieces in the next
guy
i add one to one coordinates and i add
one to the other coordinate
and the map sends an element m tensor
one
two the sum over i
x i m tensor the dual variable
that's what goes to the top piece what
goes to the bottom piece is the sum over
j
yj m tensor the dual
form on e so
so it's a very explicit map and again
it's it's a free complex where the betty
table if you like
is given entirely by the hilbert
function of m
and the differential is given by the
module structure it's given by the the
multiplication structure
so in particular you can put this into
macaulay 2
with without any serious problems it
amounts to doing a truncation of the
module and then doing some linear
algebra if you want to write down these
differentials explicitly
now i mean it's it's i claim that this
is a complex and so on so you have to
check that the differential squares to
zero
and i won't do any of that
so the way we're going to compute chief
comology groups
of of a coherent sheath is we're going
to use this construction we're going to
resolve
the kernel of these types of
differentials
so in other words we'll uh we'll define
tail sub m
of a module m to be
the free resolution
of that partial map i wrote down over
here
so you write down one map and and you
take the free resolution as e modules
over the exterior algebra
and then we get this tail
and then there's a natural way where as
e varies these
form uh uh cis uh an inductive
system and so i'll also define the tape
resolution
of my module e to be the limit
module uh excuse me yeah you're right
oops the tape resolution of the the
sheaf associated to the module e
um because what i'm about to write down
it turns out will only depend on the
module
the tape resolution will be the limit
as m goes to infinity and there's a
limit prime i'll say what that is in a
minute of
of these tails
i need to introduce a shift
and by limit prime there's some sort of
you you want to restrict to
elements of bounded degrees in the limit
so there's some sort of restricted limit
you take
but so the idea here is is
you can write down this differential
explicitly and then you can resolve it
and if you let the kind of m1 m2 run off
to infinity you get you get a
maps among the corresponding tails among
the free resolutions
and if you patch those together you get
this global object
which is called the tape resolution
of the sheaf associated the m
and then the theorem is that um this
state resolution
computes all of the comology groups all
at once
there's a similar theorem over a single
projective space
but i'll just state the theorem for for
products
and the theorem is joint with
eisenbud and schreyer
it says this it says that t
this complex uh is an
everywhere exact
vibrated
free complex of e-modules
betty numbers
compute
the chief columnology of e or of
m tilde
so there's a formula that relates them
so if you look at the ice
term and the tate resolution oops switch
notation
maybe the i term and the tate resolution
what you get is the direct sum
uh
you get a direct sum of the chief
colonology groups you're interested in
all right so so in other words if you
want to understand the chief chromology
groups if you want to compute them
it amounts to understanding and
computing the state resolution that's
really the upshot
and this is something which is happening
over the exterior algebra
and for time purposes i'm going to have
to
jump ahead of it let me see
um so
i want to say a couple things there's a
parallel theorem for a single projective
space
um but it ends up being much more
difficult for the case of
products of projective spaces and it has
to do with the fact that
these tape resolutions they're they're
not a single
term is a finitely generated free module
so if you kind of unravel this
definition
each of these is a free module of
infinite rank and so
working with them and kind of
understanding uh
how to actually get access to this i
mean so you know every term is infinite
rank so you can't write down a single
differential in macaulay 2
right that's sort of thing good if you
want to actually compute this in
macaulay 2
uh this theorem as phrase doesn't tell
you how to do that
because because you either have to take
a limit or you have to
deal with infinite rank matrices and
we don't have access to that um
but it turns out that that the exactness
uh you know this is an exact bi-graded
complex
and in fact it's kind of the exactness
is over-determined in some sense so
there are lots of sub-quotient complexes
of this guy
that are still exact and and that are
good enough for producing uh any finite
number of terms that you're interested
in right and in particular
this is this also allows us to compute a
kind of analog of valence and moan ads
for for products of projective spaces
um but let me just show let me just end
with uh
showing that that you can actually do
this and showing how to what what kind
of a computation looks like for a module
so let's see i'll just unmute this and
do one more quick
computation
i'm going to give that other door
another push oh yeah thank you
oh the other one thank you
so let's see so so i'm going to take p1
cross p2 this time
and i'm going to compute the chief
chromology of the structure sheath
so i'll compute it in the range negative
2 negative 4 up to positive 2
positive 4. and uh
and so first of all you can compute any
kind of finite portion of the tape
resolution so this is the betty table
of the tape resolution where because
it's hard to
display by gradings the by grading has
been collapsed so but you can see
there's kind of these
high rank terms and if you want to see
the commonology table
there it is so here's the chief
chromology of o on p1 cross p2
which is kind of these these uh
what's it called products um so you know
there's the p1 factor and the p2 factor
and you get this kind of kunith formula
this multiplication formula you know
here's a
uh here's just another example where we
do like a rank eight
um vector bundle on p1 cross p2
and again you can kind of get the chief
chromology groups i guess i should have
explained the notation
the power of h is which coimology group
so here you're seeing kind of h1
comology groups and h3 comology groups
and h2s
and h0s and so on so
so anyways we've got it up and running
and i think it's even online at this
point
frank's website so all right anyways
i'll stop here
are there any questions for them
so let's say i'm really selfish and i
only care about tensor products of
vector spaces and ring
greens over those okay can i use your
theory to say resolve some modules over
that ring
knowing the resolution over the
modules over the tensor product
space so let's see so you can see all
the sheaf coamology
over this i mean the the tape resolution
kind of ties together the sheath
homology for every embedding all at once
so if you were caring about chief
chromology questions you could do that
certainly if you want to know the kind
of free resolution
after you've mapped it forwards compared
it over the [ __ ] spring i don't know of
anything along those lines
and so so it depends a bit which
which particular properties you want the
resolution of the segregated is known
ideal yeah i wonder if you can take or
if you can compute that with your
methods for instance let's see
i mean the free resolution yeah the free
resolution of the idea of the segregated
product
i mean so not no no we don't know how to
do that i mean it's kind of the opposite
it's more
i think the kind of the
the approach is more effective for
computing things mapped into products of
projective spaces
right what should the resolution look
like as a sub-variety
you know if the target space is
projective space then then i don't know
that we
it's kind of the opposite that's kind of
a different question right we have more
access to
if your target space is a product then
we can
we can offer some new ideas about what
the resolution might look like and how
to approach it
does that does that distinction make
sense well i think in this case if you
want to calculate the resolution of the
segregate
you can take this energy bundle right so
you can take this uh product of this
tensor product of space is mapping to o
one
take the kernel calculation equal
multiple exterior powers and you will
get the resolution
so if you can calculate chief chromology
then you can
still do this but yeah
oh yeah yeah i see i see
and i think that steven's idea gives
doesn't give the maps either because
they
might right he'll give you the four
groups yeah exactly
in fact it must be the same i think
that's good
but you'll have with those exterior
powers you're going to have lots of
saturation issues
other questions
i just take the billions and more like
from one factor case and let's write
the obvious thing for multiple factors
if i just take the baileys and monash
from the first one factor case and at
the doctor's
by doing the tape resolution but yeah
the the kind of natural thing works you
can kind of see it would work
because the natural resolution of the
diagonal plays well with
with products um you just take the
tensor prompt and you get a resolution
with diagonal
there but if you wanted to write it down
i think this is
you know i think that our tate
resolution is the only way you actually
produce it
and what about the other touring ah good
question
um it's it's very open i mean we have
some hope
that uh something like this should work
for for smooth torque varieties
in morgan both both of the things i
spoke about
um but but the picture is much less
clear
in both cases all sorts of new
challenges
i can tell you more about it after they
get pretty serious
more questions let's
thank then again